[Music]
on this Tuesday night making face masks
mandatory the new rules in two major
Canadian cities met with compliance I'm
fine with it and resistance the next
city that may force people to cover up
their face in his own words the
disturbing letter from the man accused
of threatening the Prime Minister a
global news exclusive knew blockage a
new US Court ruling that could make
Keystone XL a pipe dream and rising
waters and a rising death toll a
torrential rain ravaging southern Japan
and going streaking through the sky just
what I thought it couldn't get any
better
a rare comet hurtling past earth that
has star gazers star struck
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we're going to get to the mandatory
rules on mask wearing in some cities in
just a moment but we begin with new
insight Global News has learned into
what may have motivated the man charged
with uttering or conveying a threat to
cause death or bodily harm to prime
minister justin trudeau 46 year old
Corey hirin a member of the Canadian
Armed Forces was arrested after ramming
his truck through the gates of Rideau
Hall on July 2nd he's facing 22 charges
and court documents reveal he had four
loaded guns including a semi-automatic
rifle and a prohibited high-capacity
magazine our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson joins me Mercedes it
seems clear he had the capacity to do
serious harm and you have exclusive
information about a note her and had
with him what does it reveal Donna
Global News now knows what was in the
note that Corey hirin wrote in advance
of smashing his truck through the gates
of rito hall with a small arsenal of
firearms hirin composed a two-page
letter in shaky and difficult to read
handwriting according to sources who are
familiar with the document the letter is
a mix of personal despair and financial
distress distressed pardon me combined
with comments on kovat 19 and clear
anger at the Liberal government in it
húrin begins by identifying himself and
saying he is now likely considered a
missing person he apologizes to his wife
the military and his other family and
friends for the trouble he says this
will cause and has caused indicating he
simply doesn't see another way forward
that he can live with he says that he
cannot keep living in his current pain
hirin talks about his business failing
and doubts that it will ever recover
even after kovat 19 passes he talks
about financial troubles too saying that
he believes he had to act now before his
truck the one he used to smash through
the gates is repossessed he then goes on
to criticize Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau in his government
describing Canada as a communist
dictatorship railing against new gun
control measures and government spending
as well as Parliament not sitting in the
letter húrin reveals that he has emailed
MPs with his concerns but says they did
not write him back hirin says that he
can
handle another year under what he calls
house arrest with kovat 19 her in'
describes his actions as what he hopes
to be a wake-up call or a turning point
for the country he says that he has
loved his time being in the Rangers and
in the military he also reveals that he
arrived here in Ottawa on Canada Day and
he laments that he went to the War
Museum only to find it closed due to
Cove at 19 he reveals he spent time near
the artillery memorial here in Ottawa he
was a member of the artillery reserves
between 1997 and 2000 he signs off by
saying he hopes he will be forgiven
one day and that his children will
understand he never is specific in the
letter dona about what exactly he's
going to do but one source described the
letter as sounding like the last one a
person would write we asked terrorism
expert lawyer and former military
officer Leo West what she took away from
the information in that letter
I'm sure the RCMP in the inset is doing
to really kind of get a good sense of
what this person's motive and intent was
and it doesn't seem that he was able to
clearly make that known through his
letter and it may be that he was
motivated for a variety of reasons and
that's what it does sound like in the
letter that his motivations were not
strictly political and that a lot of it
had to do with his own personal GRU
business Mercedes usual you've also
heard from sources that her and
communicated with someone in the
military before ramming the gate at
Rideau Hall what have you learned
Donna sources say that her and texted
his letter the both pages in terms of
photos to his superior and the Rangers
before he crashed through the gates of
Rideau Hall and sources say that when
his superior saw that text message he
called 911 call the police to let them
know what was happening to be on alert
and he continued to provide them with
information throughout the incident in
the hopes of de-escalating the situation
Donna all right Mercedes Stevenson in
Ottawa thanks the advice over whether to
wear a non-medical mask in public has
been evolving through the many long
months
this pandemic and now Canada's largest
city and the nation's capital have taken
things a step further it's now mandatory
in Toronto and Ottawa to wear a mask in
enclosed public places the number of new
cases of kovat 19 in Ontario is trending
downward 112 new cases were reported
today most in the Greater Toronto Area
and the curve has flattened
substantially right across the country
clusters of new cases when they happen
tend to be linked to enclosed spaces
like nail salons restaurants meatpacking
plants and farms with migrant workers
Toronto's public health officer says
making mass mandatory rather than just
encouraging their use improves
compliance mic relay reports on the
rules and the response this was expected
on the first day of mandatory mass in
Toronto a vocal minority protesting
infringement on their right to freedom
but most everywhere else in the city the
non-punitive by law mandating mass be
worn indoors was met with a shrug and
compliance months ago over 50 countries
around the world have made masks
mandatory in Canada right now it's just
two cities Toronto and Ottawa where the
new bylaws give businesses the right to
refuse service while also creating the
possibility of more conflict it's
unfortunate I would like us to be more
reliant upon individual responsibility
but it seems that is insufficient
what's insufficient for Montreal
retailers is how far the city's new mask
bylaw which goes into effect at the end
of the month will reach masks might soon
be mandatory within Montreal but all its
suburbs have yet to follow suit we have
to look forward for regional super
regional or even provincial a regulation
on that issue that would be way easier
for for everyone it's an issue British
Columbia seems to be grappling with as
well we're a provincial health officer
dr. Bonnie Henry has said she fully
supports wearing masks and doors she
just has no interest at this time in
making it mandatory
it depends very much on your
transmission in your community so I do
not believe we're at the point where we
need to mandate it and I don't believe
we have been there and the numbers do
support that on the same day this week
BC had seven new cases Quebec 74 and
Ontario 154 all numbers that pale in
comparison to what we were seeing during
the height of the pandemic the Cova 19
crisis has become more of a regionalized
issue putting more pressure on local
health officials and politicians to make
tough and sometimes unpopular decisions
Micro Lake Global News Toronto wearing a
mask is mandatory inside Toronto's
Pearson International Airport and the
federal Conservative leader and a
premier of Manitoba are being criticized
after pictures were posted on social
media showing them without masks Andrew
Shearer and Brian Pallister were sitting
with a group in the departures area they
were not wearing masks in early June
Pearson Airport made wearing a
non-medical mask mandatory for all
travelers and employees inside the
terminal at all times
Brazil's president refused to wear a
mask until he was ordered to do so by a
judge and now Gyre bolson ro has tested
positive for the novel coronavirus which
he's repeatedly dismissed as just a
little cold he said I would do that to
you Olsen ro says he got tested after he
began to feel unwell on Sunday at one
point during this news conference he
took off his mask and said he's feeling
just fine he also told reporters he's
taking hydroxychloroquine and as this
roam Ison and that he had an x-ray of as
long as that showed they're clear while
scenario has come under intense
criticism for minimising the seriousness
of the pandemic he's called the virus a
mild flu as his country's death toll
mounted Brazil is now the second worst
hit country in the world after the
United States more than 65,000
Brazilians are known to have died from
kovat 19 and more than 1.6 million
people have tested positive it's likely
many more cases have gone undetected
because of limited testing that kind of
rampant spread of the virus in Brazil is
something officials in Australia are
trying to avoid as crystal commencing
report
they're going to extremes to try to get
an outbreak in the country's
second-largest city under control it's a
pandemic and it will kill thousands of
people if it gets completely away from
us it's a risk Australian leaders are
not willing to take kovat 19 infections
in the state of Victoria hit levels not
seen in months
to suppress the spread a lockdown is
being imposed on nearly 5 million people
in Melbourne it's like the iceberg
analogy isn't it there's been a lot
going on that we didn't know was there
and all of a sudden I've come to the
surface and everyone's a bit freaked out
about 199 cases were reported Tuesday it
may not seem like a lot but it is for
Australia and infections are occurring
through community transmission for the
first time since this Spanish flu the
border between Victoria and New South
Wales has been closed only under special
circumstances are people granted
permission to cross this is I know
further than we went last time
but we are in many respects in a more
precarious challenging and potentially
tragic position in many countries the
pandemic is accelerating worldwide
infections have increased by nearly 1
million in roughly a week more than 200
scientists called on the World Health
Organization to acknowledge the
possibility the virus can be airborne
spread through tiny particles that
linger in the air we acknowledge that
there is emerging evidence in this field
as in all other fields regarding the
covered 19 virus and pandemic and
therefore we believe that we have to be
open to this evidence as scientists
continue to examine the virus and how
its most often spread people are trying
to stay virus free and for millions in
Australia that means staying at home
Christel commencing Global News London
the World Health Organization says it's
sending a team back to China to study
the origins of the novel coronavirus and
how it jumped from animals to humans the
team will depart this weekend for Wuhan
where the first human cases of the
mysterious pneumonia were linked to a
local wet market China's been heavily
criticized for initial secrecy about the
outbreak the US and President Donald
Trump have been highly critical of the
World Health Organization blaming it for
being too slow to react to the pandemic
for months
president Trump has criticized the
organization and now the u.s. is acting
on its threat to pull out of the World
Health Organization altogether
it's one of the biggest funders and
according to US media reports the Trump
administration has formally notified the
UN it's triggering the process to
withdraw it's expected to take one year
the u.s. is still top of the charts of
kovat 19 cases in the world and the
numbers are surging in a number of
states more than 46,000 more Americans
tested positive just today that brings
the total number of infections to more
than 2.9 million here in Canada the
federal government has signed an
agreement with the Assembly of First
Nations outlining how it will fund the
plan to overhaul the First Nations child
welfare system it's the next step
towards implementing bill C 92 that's
the legislation that gives indigenous
communities control over child welfare
and aims to reduce the number of kids in
care not all provinces are on board
Quebec has launched a constitutional
challenge to the law arguing child
welfare is a provincial responsibility
instead of wasting all the tax dollars
fighting this bill is to start working
with Chiefs and leadership to implement
this bill it's really in the best
interest of the children
there's too many children in foster care
under provincial systems and we've said
it this way that you've got to focus on
the children keep them at home in their
communities and their families Assembly
of First Nations estimates there are
40,000 indigenous children in foster
care across Canada and that's more than
double the number of kids taken from
their families when residential schools
were at their peak members of a House of
Commons committee have agreed to look
into why grocery store chains have cut
pandemic pay premiums for workers
union leaders representing thousands of
grocery store workers say there's no
reason to cut the premium since Kovac 19
is still a risk for workers some have
become ill and a few have died from the
virus when the outbreak struck Canada in
March great major grocery store chains
boosted frontline workers wages by about
$2 an hour late last month the chains
announced they were ending the pay bump
because the pace the business has eased
a developing disaster in Japan coming up
what's in the forecast after widespread
flash floods plus pipeline pushback the
latest obstacle for Keystone XL
the Keystone XL pipeline has suffered
yet another setback the US Supreme Court
rejected a request from the Trump
administration to allow construction of
parts of the Keystone XL pipeline that
have been blocked by a federal judge in
Montana the court upheld a lower court
ruling and is Eric Sorenson reports
after years of legal battles that means
the future of the pipeline is again up
in the air this project is about Alberta
taking control of its destiny
just days after Alberta's premier kicked
off construction of the Keystone XL
pipeline the mega project is stalled
once again from the US Supreme Court a
non-decision thunderbolt rejecting a bid
from the Trump administration to allow
Keystone construction that's been
blocked by a Montana judge the massive
project would ship more than 800,000
barrels of crude from Alberta's oil
sands to refineries on the US Gulf Coast
the Canadian company behind the pipeline
says in a statement TC energy remains
committed to the future of this project
the court decision comes as a coalition
of environmental organizations urges
Ottawa to chart a new path away from oil
and towards climate protection the
International Institute for sustainable
development says billions of federal
dollars that will be spent recovering
from kovat 19 should come with green
strings attached for the carbon economy
support only for companies that agree to
net zero emissions by 2050 for the new
economy stimulus to build a green
recovery with green jobs in short this
is no time for Alberta or Ottawa to
spend billions on pipelines says the
reports co-author the Alberta government
has maintained the economic recovery
from kovat 90 needs Canadian oil it will
only happen if we get pipelines built
but the oil sector is struggling Ottawa
spent four billion dollars on the
proposed TMX pipeline expansion from
Alberta to B see that several indigenous
groups still oppose all this at a time
when oil prices are low and some
investors are pulling
as economic recovery unfolds how much
how much net new investment do we see in
the oil and gas sector so I think it's
going to take several years for the oil
and gas sector to get back to its its
pre kovat levels of activity given the
the dramatic economic shock that's
taking place as for Keystone XL
Democratic presidential candidate Joe
Biden has vowed to scrap Donald Trump's
approval of it which means a project now
stopped by the courts is uncertain to
restart after November's US election
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto still
ahead a bus ride turns tragic for
students in China
you are watching global national crews
in southern Japan are trudging through
knee-deep water trying to rescue people
trapped by flooding at least 55 people
have been killed after days of
torrential rain and landslides and at
least a dozen people are missing over
1.3 million others have been ordered to
leave their homes and more rain is in
the forecast through Thursday in
southwestern China 21 people have been
killed when a bus plunged into a lake
video shows the bus suddenly swerve off
the word road break through a fence and
then plunge into the water the
passengers are believed to have been
high school students on their way to
exams state media says at least 18
people on board were rescued United
Nations investigators say Syria's
pro-government forces and its rebel
opponents flagrantly violated the laws
of war during the battle for it Lib
province the new UN report says
civilians endured what it calls
unfathomable suffering and were subject
to indiscriminate air strikes ground
shelling arrests and torture when
Syria's military launched its deadly
campaign late last year hundreds of
civilians were killed before a ceasefire
was finally agreed in March about 1
million people were displaced and many
have been forced to live in overcrowded
camps
the early bird gets a magnificent sight
next how to spot comet NEOWISE the
pandemic has a lot of us staying home
sometimes without much to do but the
universe is giving us a good reason to
get up early in the morning to see what
many are calling the most impressive
comet in years Mike Armstrong explains
this is the comet NEOWISE as seen over
Switzerland just breaking over the
horizon that's its tail fanned out
behind it now stargazers had two other
comets in 2020 they were looking forward
to both turned out to be disappointments
that is not the case with this one
Neil wise is actually brighter than
expected here it is shot from Burlington
Ontario in the sky over Toronto it's
small but spectacular this photo was
snapped by an astronaut in the space
station this one by an amateur
photographer and Lebanon it's NASA's
official Astronomy Picture of the Day so
about once a decade you get one that is
really bright naked-eye visibility and
that's what surprisingly NEOWISE has
become we weren't expecting it the comet
is named after the NEOWISE spacecraft
the infrared wavelength space telescope
that discovered it it's been visible
with inexpensive ground telescopes and
even binoculars from the southern
hemisphere for a while on its way
towards the Sun as it's gotten closer
it's become easier to see from the
northern hemisphere and brighter it's
rare that comets are so visible with the
naked eye so what is it while comets are
sometimes called dirty snowballs they're
ice and rock and dust the tail is gas
and dust blown off by the sun's heat and
solar wind the glow comes from molecules
breaking down as it gets close to the
Sun you heat it up and that's what
creates the tail now NEOWISE survived
its pass around the Sun last week that's
when most comets disappear this one's
still going it's going to fade as it
moves away from the Sun but not as
quickly as usual because it's getting
closer to Earth the show will continue
for several days to spot it look low on
the horizon to the northeast it's
visible in the early morning now but as
it gets closer to her
it'll be earlier and earlier Mike
Armstrong Global News Montreal and that
is global national for this Tuesday I'm
Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada is
Killarney Ontario beautiful scene thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]